Speaker 1: This next story would not be believable
if we hadn't been seeing exactly this type of
projection for the last who knows how many
years from the American Republican Party?
Herschel Walker, the Trump endorsed
Republican Senate candidate from Georgia,
has been a big critic of absentee fathers. In
fact, he's run a campaign very much based around
cultural issues critical race theory, which he
mistook misstated as C TR, which is usually an
abbreviation for click through rate, which is an
online advertising term. Anyway, he meant CRT.
He's been talking about CRT. He's been talking
about absentee fathers and all of these different
things. We had two layers of insanity. First, it
was revealed that Herschel Walker actually has
another son. He has one son that kind of is
in the public eye named Christian Walker.
It was revealed that Herschel Walker
has another son that he doesn't see.
He is an absentee father to another son. After
that story came out, it was revealed that Herschel
Walker actually has even more kids to whom he
is an absentee father, I guess we would say.
He is not really a father. Is every allegation a
confession from these people? So let's go through
it piece by piece and then we'll talk about the
hypocrisy. So first, we have an article from The
New York Times. This is from two days ago. And the
article says Herschel Walker, critic of absentee
fathers, has a second son that he doesn't see.
The article is from making Herschel Walker the
Republican nominee for Senate from Georgia, who
has often spoken out against absentee fathers,
particularly in black households, on Tuesday
publicly acknowledged having fathered a second son
with whom he is not in contact. The admission came
in response to a report by The Daily Beast which
said it confirmed the ten year old boy's parentage
but withheld his name and that of the mother.
It says the child's mother has sued Walker a year
after giving birth to obtain a declaration of
paternity and child support. And the suit lasted
until August 2014, when Walker was ordered to pay
child support. The boy, by then, more than
two years old, took Walker's last name. Okay,
so that's already crazy like that. That's already.
Wow. So you're going out there saying not just in
general, we have a problem with absentee fathers,
but in the black community. We have a problem with
absentee fathers. And he is he is part of that
problem. Okay. But then it gets even crazier
because then this morning, another piece comes
out in The Daily Beast. Herschel Walker, critic
of absentee dads, admits to yet another secret
son. And it's this isn't the first secret son that
was reported. This is another one. This article
by article is by Roger Sullenberger. And it says
A day after The Daily Beast broke the news that
Herschel Walker had a secret ten year old son,
the football star turned politician
confirmed late Wednesday. He has yet
another son with a different woman, as
well as a daughter that he had in college.
Walker said in September of 2020. I want to
apologize to the African-American community
because the fatherless home is a major, major
problem. He added in an interview with diamond
and silk, men need to go into neighborhoods and
become fathers of those fatherless children.
The second of Walker's previously undisclosed sons
was born to a woman living in Texas and is now 13.
Walker's other son is ten. Christian
Walker, who's the publicly known one,
is 22. The Daily Beast is withholding the
names of the younger sons and their mothers.
There's a bunch of different layers to this
story. Okay. First, it's the heavy projection
that we are constantly seeing from the Republican
Party. Trump's about family values. Supposedly
evangelicals vote for me. I love the Bible and I
love to Corinthians and all this different stuff.
Except Trump's been divorced multiple times and
he's cheated endlessly, and he has children with
with different women and all these things that the
evangelicals claim to care about. And Trump says,
Vote for me anyway. And then they do because
they really don't like Hillary Clinton. Okay.
So like that's one layer, the double standard,
the hypocrisy that that's certainly part of
this. But there's also kind of another element to
this, which is the Republican Party at this point
only cares about virtue signaling around
these issues rather than actual policy.
And they apply different standards to their
own than to others. And this is unfortunately,
it's not something that we can fix because you
can't get other people to actually care about
being consistent. You have to remember that
the way the Republican Party works right now
is they say it's basically this thought process.
Democrats are evil, socialist, communist,
whatever, baby killing. Right. All the different
stuff. Sodomites, some of them like to say
whatever it is that they say, they start with
that. So we absolutely can't have any Democrats
in office. We've got to vote for Republicans. The
reason we claim that we do that is because the
Republicans are pro-life and the Republicans are
pro-family and they're godly and they have faith
in all of these different things. Oh, okay. Well,
look at Trump. Trump's a guy who was pro-choice
his entire life until he all of a sudden needed
to come up with some explanation for being pro
anti-choice, pro-life, as they call it, to run
for president. And he's been divorced and he's
cheated and he's not religious. He never went to
church. But I don't know. Now he says he likes the
Bible. Okay. Even though it's obvious that Trump
doesn't meet any of their requirements, remember,
they hate Hillary. They're not going to vote for
the Democrats. So they go, we'll accept it. We'll
accept Trump's bogus story about how he came
to be against abortion and will accept Trump's
bogus story about how now he's religious and two
Corinthians and all of that. And then it's proven
to be false time and time again. And they just
go, Yeah, well, no, but it doesn't matter. I mean,
Hillary, Hillary was even worse. Hillary is just
absolutely terrible. It's never actually about
any of the things they claim it's about. It never
is. It's just a justification to create a context
to keep voting for the people that say the right
things, even if they're completely unbelievable.
Now, this will be a test for Herschel Walker
in Georgia. Georgia has become very sort of
weaponized Trumpist as we saw. But at the same
time, in the in some of the primaries in Georgia,
the Trump endorsed candidate didn't win. And even
though Trump did endorse Herschel Walker, this may
be too much for these Georgia voters. Now, the
funny thing about it is I would be willing to
accept if Herschel Walker from the beginning.
Did a sort of do as I say, not as I do thing.
I don't think that that's completely illegitimate.
Speaker 3: I don't like. I would be.
Speaker 1: Willing to accept someone being upfront
and saying, listen, I think that we have a problem
in general or in the black community. However,
he wants to phrase it with absentee fathers.
And unfortunately, I'm a part of that problem.
I did X, Y, Z, and I'm not in touch with these
kids. And it's been bad for me and it's been bad
for the kids and it's been bad for the mothers.
And I am going through a journey of personal
rediscovery and I am trying to make amends and
fix it. You guys know what I'm saying? If
he just owned it, I think you could still
credibly say and because I know this issue so
personally, it's a really important one that I
want to work on. That's not what he did. Okay.
He didn't do that. And so now there's going to
be a question as to whether this is the straw
that breaks the camel's back with these Georgia
voters. I don't know if it's going to be,
but we're going to follow it. And we will see